because you start feeling a greater  sense of unity you start feeling a  greater sense of oneness  you start feeling not only the oneness  with the  environment and the planet but you start  feeling the oneness with each other  at a deeper level so the same unity that  you feel with your  family members you start expressing that  same unconditional love unity  to your friends and to the world at  large  and then that is  infused into everything you create  from then on and so that's really the  big shift that's happened in the last  six years  for me is now being able to really  infuse  the essence of unity and oneness  into everything that i do and  because of asking those big questions  and getting to the bottom of the truth